put two Pat's point right now look that
sounds well and good and you know and
and for for the record I hold xrp so I
hope it does 5x but right now it's like
75 cents correct so you're not talking
about 250 billion you're talking like 40
billion all right and the US government
has nothing but money and time so from
the outside looking in I'm not an
attorney but this looks frivolous this
looks like somebody's trying to lean on
somebody this looks like maybe I don't
know you know uh like you said MoneyGram
Western Union decided to get a couple
senators in there and say you know this
is going to put us completely out of
business like we make 25 we make 25
cents out of every dollar transferred
these guys can do this instantaneously
for no money like get rid of these guys
uh but
what's to say that they don't just keep
dragging it out dragging it out dragging
it out dragging it out bleeding you out
bleeding you out I mean how long can
they they take this if they take this
thing 10 years is Ripple going to fight
for 10 years what's what's their
breaking point before they say okay you
know what fine we're a security close
the thing down reincorporated Mexico
with this same exact white paper and
start over it's a great question the my
settlement scenario was if that pressure
point existed for ginsler that it was
gonna you know put them on a business
regulating all the other crypto because
of the precedent if those rulings don't
come down favorable for ripple then I
don't think there's a settlement I think
it goes to verdict and I think it's on
appeal and I think we are looking at a
couple years of that process at some
point Ripple could tap out and say
listen we'll we'll go with a certain
designation we can only sell to
accredited investors now you know
there's there's ways to get around it
but I don't see it happening I I see it
either settling you know because of the
those rulings that come down or it goes
to verdict and there was a verdict in
Connecticut not too long ago where a
jury came back where there was a digital
asset a small one
where they the jury said that's not an
unregistered security and so
um that's where I think we're headed
so so let me go back to that though let
me go back to that because the point was
we have two things settle and dismiss
right you almost want settlement more
than you want to be dismissed right
because if they dismiss it then that
means hey we're coming back again and
again and again and again and again
right so there's a part of Brad and
Chris and the 62 000 and it's 62 000
you're represented but there's more xrp
of course so what's the number 456 I I
saw a number like 450 500 000 xrp
holders something like some number like
that right so so if they if they dismiss
and they don't do anything what happens
then then we have this Cloud hanging
over us and what Gerard said I think you
had when you had Kurt I was watching
that video when you had Kurt on yeah and
and Gerard summed up the unfortunate
nature of what's happening in this
country he literally said
um Ripple is similar to bitcoin they
were just dumb enough to do it in the
United States I mean that's something it
up we'll be right there where there'll
be this uncertainty and right now you
have Gary Gensler saying come in and
talk to us come in and talk to us as
soon as they they're using those
interviews as a way to learn information
about the company as soon as you leave
by time you get to your office you have
a subpoena Brian Armstrong of coinbase
was trying to negotiate with them over
that Lynn product and all of a sudden he
shares with him all that information he
goes in and he talks to him and then
what do they say if you bring that Lin
product we're going to sue you
why do you think they did want to be the
first to to incorporate the United
States they're obviously not dumb guys
why do you think they want they wanted
this fight I feel like I feel like they
kind of maybe not the SEC maybe not the
way that they've gone after it but I
feel like they they poke the bear you
know by by kind of swinging against the
current and I don't know maybe they
thought they would skip the line and be
the first that would become like some
sort of you know state-backed you know
uh you know as EB Tucker called it fed
coin right I don't know what what their
what the intention was I don't know what
kind of conversation you have with them
but but have they ever described to you
what their thinking was with making this
and you know an American product no I
I've never never spoken to them you know
and a lot of a lot of my critics will
say oh you know he's a plant for ripple
look what he's doing never spoken to him
um there was a report done by Fox
Business on this story and they said
Deaton's no Fanboy of Ripple I don't got
anything against him I'm an xrp holder I
want them to be successful because if
they're successful the whole ecosystem
grows but um but I don't know know why a
lot of people ask that question so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye
[Music]